I'm all celebrating when you able to do
something good in the toughest sport in
the history of the universe man you got
to be able to celebrate it maybe we
should come up cuz like jazz doing the
the Euro Step Right Ozuna when he took a
picture down the third Baseline tatis
when he does a little Shuffle thing
around third base right in the video
games Mortal Kombat you ever played
Mortal Kombat yeah of course finishing
fatality you know the Fatal it's like
you know you knew who you were picking
you know the finishing move right and so
maybe that's kind of what how we should
view it Castillo is when he that's like
his finishing move right I'm I'm going
trying and come up with a signature or
something I don't know what it's going
to be we'll see